[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام هل ثار الشعب
التونسي
وصام ليفطر على حركه نداء تونس التي اصبحت
مضربا للمثل في الفساد والاستبداد وحكم
البوليس والاعتداء على الحريات والدين
والاقتتال الداخلي والانهيار
الوشيك اليس من الطبيعي ان ينهار هذا
التجمع
الهجين سمك على لبن على جرجير على تمر
هندي اليست حركه نداء تونس مزيجا غريبا
عجيبا من الفلول واليسار جيين
والليبراليين والراس ماليين والقبائل
والقطط السمان وحتى فرق كره
القدم كيف يتشبه السبسي ب بورقيبه بينما
يتصرف كحافظ
الاسد الم يقل بورقيبه ان السلطه لا تلد
فلماذا يريد السبسي ان يورث رئاسه حزبه
لابنه حافظ اليس حري بالتونسي ان يتصدوا
لهذا الحافظ الجديد والا رفع قريبا شعار
ال الاسد الى الابد يتساءل احدهم ساخرا
الا تسير تونس من سيء الى اسوا في عهد
النداء ورئيسه
التسعيني لكن في المقابل اليس الصراع داخل
حركه نداء تونس مظهرا ديمقراطيا اليس من
الافضل للاحزاب التونسيه الجديده ان تت
تمتع بالشفافيه حتى في صراعاتها لماذا
النيل من هذا الحزب اذا كانت غالبيه
التونسيين قد صوتوا لح اليس من الاجحاف
اتهام حركه نداء تونس بانها تمثل فقط
القوى التي تمولها في الداخل والخارج ولا
علاقه لها ابدا بتمثيل طموحات الثوره
لماذا يحمل البعض الانهيار الاقتصاديه
للرئيس السبسي وحزبه الا تمثل الحكومه كل
الاحزاب الفاعله على الساحه اليس من حق
النداء ان يتصدى للمتطرفين حتى لو اقصى
بعض ائمه المساجد واغلق بعضها الاخر الا
تواجه تونس خطر الارهاب لماذا يعتبر البعض
ضبط الاوضاع الامنيه في البلاد اعتداء على
الحريات واعاده دوله البوليس والاستبداد
اسئله اطرحها على الدكتور محمد هنيد
الاستاذ في جامعه السربون وعلى الدكتور
صالح حاج عمر القيادي في حركه نداء تونس
نبدا نقاش بعد
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس لدينا
تصويت يقول هل تعتقد ان حزب نداء تونس هو
نسخه عن حزب ابن علي المخلوع
94.7 نعم 5.3 لا لو بدات معك بهذه النتيجه
دكتور هنيد ماذا يمكن ان نقرا في هذه
النتيجه على الاقل لدينا شريحه لا نقول
دقيقه 100% لكن مؤشر خطير في واقع الامر
يعني تقول باختصار شديد ان هذا الحزب الذي
يعني يعني يتصدر المشهد في تونس الان
ويقود البلاد هو لا يختلف باي حال من
الاحوال عن الحزب الساقط اذا صح التعبير
البعض يصفه حتى بانه اان نوفمبري جديد نعم
دكتور فيصل شكرا جزيلا لك على الدعوه و
لقناه الجزيره العربيه على هذه الاستضافه
اود في البدايه ان اعزي نفسي واعزي الشعب
التونسي بالمصيبه التي حلت والتي سقط
ضحيتها 14 من خيره ابناء المؤسسه الامنيه
الذين اشتغلت معهم من الامن الرئاسي ومن
ابناء الطبقات الفقيره الذين سقطوا في
اعتداء ارهابي غاشم واعذر لي فنحن ما زلنا
على وقع الصدمه طيب اي هذا اولا
ثانيا قراءه المشهد استاذ فيصل هي كالتالي
حسب رايي يعني على الاقل الاطار العام هو
انه حدثت ثورات عربيه سلميه جوبهت بابشع
اليات القمع لكن ما يحدث اليوم يعني ما
يحدث اليوم من صراع داخل نداء تونس هو
تقريبا المرحله الرابعه او الاخيره في
محاوله استنساخ شروط النظام الاستبدادي
المرحله الرابعه هته المرحله الرابعه لان
المرحله الاولى في هي اولا عاء امتصاص
الانفجار الثوري الثانيه هي بث الفوضى
وزعزع النظام بمن لمنع الانتقال ال
ديمقراطي المرحله الثالثه هي يعني تصدر
المشهد من جديد عبر الانتخابات مثل ما حدث
بالمال الفاسد ثم ما يحدث اليوم هو ما
يسمى في يعني نظريات التغيير الاجتماعي
بصراع الانداد او حرب النظائر يعني عندما
يصفي الانداد بعضهم البعض لتبقى العمليه
لواحد فقط اعطيك امثله على ذلك حدث ذلك
مثلا خارج المنطقه العربيه في س في روسيا
عندما صفى استالين تروتسكي ومجموعته
ليستفد بالمؤسسه السياسيه حدث في سوريا
عندما انقلب حفظ الاسد على صلاح جديد وال
ما سماه بالحركه التصحيحيه حدث في مصر
عندما انقلب عبد الناصر على محمد نجيب حدث
في الجزائر عندما انقلب يعني بومدين علاء
بن بلا حدث يعني في اماكن مختلفه اخرى
يحدث نوع من اعاده انتاج الاستبداد عبر
الاستفراد بالسلطه يعني هذا هو ما يحدث
اليوم هناك صراع كبير داخل حزب نداء تونس
بشقيه الشق يعني
ال الشق الاول الذي يمثل
السيد الباجي قيد السبسي وهو يعتقد او
يصرح بانه وريث الحركه الدستوريه وشق ثاني
يمثله تقريبا جناح تقريبا
استئصالية استهداف الوضع في تونس واستهداف
حتى رئيس الجمهوريه الذي كان يريد ان يلقي
خطابا انا اعيد واكرر دكتور فيصل لست ضد
شخص مع شخص نحن مع الوحده الوطنيه عندما
تكون ضروره وحده وطنيه لان الدوله اليوم
الوطن امانه هناك اطراف تتدخل لتصفيه
حسابات واصبح الجميع مستهدف بما ذا بما في
ذلك يعني الحصن الحصين للدوله التونسيه
وقد اشتغلت معهم وعرفهم وهم يعني خيره
مقاتلي تونس قوات الامن الرئاسي الذين
سخطوا اليوم في قلب المركه طيب اذا
باختصار نحن الان في المرحله
الرابعه انتاج شروط الاستبداد بوكلاء
خارجيين اساسا يعني بوكلاء خارجيين اساسا
وليسوا في الداخل الا ادوات تنفيذيه بسيطه
مثلهم مثل الدواعش دكتور اولا وقبل كل شيء
اريد ان اترحم على شهداء الوطن من امنيين
لهته العمليه الجبانه وهذه العمليه
الجبانه هي مش تزيدنا الا قوه وما هوش
بهته العمليه اللي مش احنا اليوم مش نخاف
بالعكس هذه العمليه يلزم توصل كل
التونسيين يلزمنا اليوم نكنا نكونوا يد
واحده يد واحده ضد الارهاب هذايا اللي لا
دين له ولا مله ولا يفرق بين يساري او
يميني او مهما كانت الانتماءات الحسبيه
جميل جدا ندخل في موضوعنا اولا اللي كنت
نسمع فيه ماهوش صحيح نداء تونس هو جاء بعد
الثوره ونداء تونس والشعب التونسي ونابي
نداء تونس هما لبو النداء نظرا لفشل
الترويكا في الحكم جميل ونعرف اللي
الترويكا بعد انتخابهم في المجلس التاسيسي
اول انقلاب قاموا به هما انتخبهم الشعب
التونسي لمده سنه لكن لولا
وقوف المنظمات والمجتمع المدني كانوا
سيواصلون اكثر وهذه العمليه الاولى اللي
را يعني يعيدون انتاج الاستبداد بطريقتهم
ايش ما في شك لكن هذه اتهامات تونس بان
اتهامات ندا تونس بانه نداء تونس هو نسخه
مسبقه ل للتجمع هذا ماهو صحيح نعرفوا نداء
تونس هو يمثل
جميع التونسيين نجدو فيه اليسارين نجدو
فيه المستقلين نجدو فيه النقابيين نجدو
فيه الاترا نجدو فيه المستقلين وبالتالي
نداء تونس هو نتاج للفشل الذريع اللي قامت
به الترويكا واللي حاولت لكن لم تستطع
لانه مازالوا مافهموش اللي الشعب التونسي
شعب مغي
شعب عنده شخصيته شعب ماهوش بالهل باش
تعداها عليه ونداء تونس ه الشعارات هذه
نسمع فيها ماهيش صحيح هذايا دليل على ناس
معجبهمش نداء تونس ويحاولوا معناتها باش
يعطوها صوره معناتها ماهيش حقيقيه وماهيش
صحيحه وبالتالي ناس ما فهمتش اللي را صار
الثوره اليوم من استاذ صلاح الثوره حدثت
ضد من الثوره ضد ندا تونس ندا تونس مع
عمره كانان موجود رجال بن علي موجودين انا
معك معرجال رجال بن علي موجودين في كافه
الاحزاب بيخلص مفتي بن علي يعني الوجوه
التي تراها ليست ليست من النظام الق انت
كنت انت انت كنت صديقي انت كنت ظهر لي في
مستشار مع سي المرزوقي وكنت مع مع
المرزوقي مع مؤسسه الرئسه مع مؤسسه
الرئاسه اللي كان رئيسها سي المرزوقي اللي
اللي معناتها كان رئيس ب اكبر بقايا هذا
نعرفوه فهمني وسمحنا نكمل
كلامي تونس معناتها التشويه هذا مش في
مكانه ليس تشويه تشويه وقت نجي احنا نداء
تونس وانت حكيت معناتها ثم ايادي خارجيه
وايادي كذا هذا هذا هذا انا انا سامحني
هذايا معناتها تجني على الناس اللي تخبت
نداء تونس وعلى المناضلين الحقيقيين
الموجودين داخل نداء تونس وما تتصورش
معناتها احنا في معناتها في ظرف وجيز وهذه
ما صارت هذه المعزه داخل تونس وخارج تونس
اللي في ظرف وجيز وثلاث اشهر نداء تونس
يربح ثلاث انتخابات انتخابات تشريعيه
وانتخابات رئاسيه في دورتها الاولى
ودورتها الثانيه ظهر لي هذايا معناتها
جواب واضح على شعبيه على شعبيه بس دكتور
خليني اسال بس سؤال بسيط يعني يعني الا
تعتقد
ان هذه التشكيله او هذه التركيبه التي
يتكون منها او تتكون منها حركه نداء تونس
هي لصالح الحركه وليست ضدها في واقع الامر
البعض يعتقد بانه هذه الحركه هي سمك على
لبن على جرجير على تمر هندي على اعتبار
انها مزيج غر
على العكس تماما هذا المزيج الغريب هو
نقطه قوه بالنسبه للحركه كما قال الدكتور
باعتبار انها تمثل كافه شرائح المجتمع او
القوى السياسيه في في تونس جيد انا اتفق
معه لو كان ما قاله صحيح انا اتمنى ان
يكون كلامي خاطئ وكلامك صحيح لكن نترك
الناس تحكم يا استاذ صلاح يعني انا لا
انكر وجود وطنيين في نداء تونس انا لم اقل
ذلك السيد الباجي قب السبسي الله يطيل في
عمره لست ضده او ضد شخص نحن في مرحله
قاليه تعرف هشاشتها وانت وانت سمعت ما
قاله السيد حافظ قايد سبسي سمعت بالمشروع
الانقلابي على رئيس الجمهوريه يعني ان
تقول لي ان النداء هو جبهه موحده هذا غير
صحيح حتى المعطيات تخالف ذلك استقرائيه او
استدلال يعني العناصر الموجوده داخل نداء
تونس هي عناصر انتهازيه فيها عناصر
انتهازيه كبرى وانت تعرفها هناك ناس قال
بلفظه بعبارته نحن ل وراءنا اطراف خارجيه
يعني هذا كلام قالوا هم لم اقله انا عنهم
لكن تقول لي الترويكا حسنا يا سيدي فشلوا
انا مع النقد لست مع المرزوقي او مع
الغنوشي او مع شيء صخص انا مع الوطن معه
تونس البلد مهدد يا رجل وانا لا اقول ذلك
يعني للاطماع شخصيه انا اقول لك انه هناك
مسار ثوري الشعب التونسي انت تعرف في اي
ظروف نخب وما هو المال الذي دخل وتحدث حتى
نواب لداء تونس عن واحد يعطي خرفان وواحد
يعطي اموال من هنا ورايت كيف حدث ذلك يعني
لنمر لنذهب الى الامان ان اردت ان نذهب
الى الامان لكن هل يمكن ان نعيد نفس
الخلطه بنفس الموا السامه ونقول هذا طبق
صحي على الاقل لو لم نطرح الوضعيه
الحقيقيه رايت حجم الفقر رايت حجم التشفيه
الاجتماعي رايت بيع القطاع الخاص رايت رهن
البلد رايت ماذا يحدث للمواطن اليوم مهدد
في خبزه يعني ترى كل هذه الكوا ونقول ان
النداء هو موحد هم يقولون نس موحدين من
داخلهم وانا لا ابحث عن شق الصف او عن غير
ذلك نحن نريد ان نقول ان كان برنامج حزب
نداء تونس برنامج وطني يستعيد قضايا وطنيه
اعلى من الجميع انا اصوت له ان كان هو
تجمع انتهازي لرهن البلد وبيع الاقتصاد
وبيعه الى الاجنبي فهذا لن يدوم ولن يكون
لا في صالح نداء تونس ولا في صالح الدوله
يا استاذ محمد انا اتمنك بحاجه اللي نداء
تونس فيه من الوطنيين والمفكرين والمثقفين
والاحرار هذا هذايا حتى اربع حكومات هذايا
لا مجال حتى حد م مجم يزايد فينا عليه
ومجم يناقشنا فيه لكن سمحني ما نقص عليك
انا نحب ح
ح
تونس قصد نعطي انطباع جيد يعني غير
الانطباع اللي ماخذين الناس عن نداء تونس
حيث يتضاربون
بالكراسي
ر بس مشان مشان نوضح الصوره انت تعلم الان
حركه نداء تونس اصبحت مضربا للمثل في
الفساد وفي الاقتتال الداخلي وفي التناحر
وفي الخبط وفي الكراسي لم يتركوا شيء يعني
اصبح نموذجا للبلطجه السياسيه وجاي تقول
لي حضاره و لا لا انا لا لا اوافق في هذا
الاتجاه قلت لك نداء تونس معناتها هو خيار
بالنسبه للشعب التونسي خاصه بعد فشل
الترويكا وبالتالي نداء تونس احنا ما كانش
عندنا الوقت فهمني ماعملناش هياكل لانه
الظرف
وقتها ما يسمحش باش مش نعمل هياكل
محليه ف جهويه ف وطنيه وبالتالي كنا
معنتها ماشيين دخلنا نداء تونس وتكون نداء
تونس لمشروع معين وهو انقاذ تونس في
الفتره هذيك اليوم يقول القائل بيان س
معنتها وصلنا الى حد يلزم مناداه بمؤتمر
واعاده هيكله نداء تونس هذا يطلب العديد
من من الوقت اين هو اين هو المؤتمر
بالتالي الخلافات الموج اين هو المؤتمر
لماذا لم يتفقوا حتى الان على مؤتمر تاسيس
لهذه الحركه هذا هنا الاختلاف اللي موجود
داخل نداء تونس هي حاله صحيه مش نختلف في
الاراء معناتها معناتها نصبح اعداء كل
واحد عنده وجهه نظر اعه وبالتالي هذه نقطه
ايجابيه لنداء تونس شفافيه ما فيش شكل
فهمني وبالتالي احنا توا في عمليه المؤتمر
هناك اطراف تنادي بمؤتمر انتخابي واطراف
اخرى تنادي بمؤتمر تاسيسي هنا نقطه
الاختلاف وهذا مش يعني معناتها مش نوصل
انتهت الحركه او الدمار بالعكس احنا هناك
نقاشات فهمني لازم في كل حزب معناتها لازم
تلقى بعض الانفلاتات وهذا يرجع يمكن الى
البعض اللي ناقص من التجربه او الحنكه
السياسيه لكن هناك عقلاء داخل نداء تونس
وانا من مصلحه تونس اللي نداء تونس يكون
حزب قوي من مصلحه تونس اللي نداء تونس
معناتها هو الحزب الحاكم واللي يلزمنا
نكون سند للحكومه لانه ماك تعرف الحكومه
هي حكومه رئيس الحكومه مستقله والحكومه
ماهيش كل ل حكومه نداء تونس وبالتالي وزير
واحد يعني فيها وزير من النهضه الحكومه
فيها وز فيها وزير من النهضه فيها وزره من
افق تونس فيها وزره من الاتحاد الوطني
الحر ف ف ف فيها وزره مستقلين بالتالي
ماهمش كلهم نداء تونس وانت تعرف علاش حتى
البعض يلومنا احنا م اربحنا الانتخابات
باغلبيه
مريحه طيب بس انا انا هذه النقطه اريد ان
اجليها طيب يعني لماذا هذا هذه الماخذ على
نداء تونس انهم يتصارعون على السلطه وانهم
مشتتون وانهم يتقاتلون الرجل يقول لك انه
لماذا لا نعتبر ذلك مظهرا ديمقراطيا خاصه
واننا في العالم العربي غير معتادين على
هذه الصراعات المعلنه والمكشوفه خاصه داخل
الاحزاب لنعتبر ذلك شفافيه حتى في اظهار
الصراعات م العي في ذلك نتمنى ذلك اتمنى
ذلك من بكل صدق لكن فاقد الشيء لا يعطيه
يعني تجمع الجماعه ليس تجمع انا انا اعطيك
تصريحات المسؤولين داخل نداء تونس يعني لم
اتي بالروايه من عندي ان الوضع ال يعني
يعني ان حزب نشا البارحه واكتسح العمليه
بما تعرف انت يعني يتحول الى حزب ديمقراطي
يعني مباشره و الع حسنا انظر لو كان لو
كانت المساله التي نريد ان نتحدث عنها
مساله سياسيه المساله مساله الفشل والعجز
ليست مساله سياسيه هي اساسا مساله
اقتصاديه اولا امنيه ثانيا اجتماعيه ثالثا
ليست مساله سياسيه هذا الرقص مع الذئاب
الذي يصورونه لنا والشطحات من هنا وهناك
واختلاق الازمات السياسيه للايام بان
المساله مساله سياسيه هذا غير صحيح الصراع
الحقيقي في تونس هو صراع تراه بين اجهزه
امنيه وصراع اجتماعي حول الشعار الابرز في
ثوره شباب تونس ثوره 17 ديسمبر وهو
التشغيل استحقاق يا عصابه القراق هل حاسب
نداء السراق هل حاسب هل حاسب نداء تونس
احدهم والله لو الباجي قاد السبسي غدا
يمسك القناصه ا انا انا انا ادعو له على
المنابر الاعلاميه طبعا يعني هل هناك
محاسبه حدثت هل هناك غربله حدثت هل هناك
ما انتم غرب شو غربله شو على الاقل لرجال
العلمان الذي تسببوا في كل هذا الخراب انت
راين ابن عم يعني هذا مبروك السلطاني
قاللك نحن ناكل خبيزه ناس تطبخ في العشب
يا رجل يا رجل الناس لا تستطيع ان تداوي
انفسها اليوم وان تتحدثوا عن هذا الشق
وديمقراطيه الناس طالبت بعداله اجتماعيه
طالبت بحد ادنى اهالي القصرين يذهبون من
القصرين على ارجلهم الى العاصمه طلبا
للعمل يا رجل ونحن نتحدث عن تماسيح
بملايين المليارات الناطق باسم الحكومه
وليس كلام يعني تحدث قال يوميا تخسر تونس
ما يقارب 500 مليار من المليمات 500 مليون
دولار من نهب الثروات البترول والغاز هل
تم ايقاف النزيف على الاقل ايقاف النزيف
هل تمت محاربه الفساد رايت القروض التي
اعطيت بالاف المليارات اليوم نرهن يعني
ملعب ساقس اليوم نرهن ملعب رادس يعني الى
اين نذهب هل للنداء امكانيه حقيقيه
للسيطره امنيا واجتماعيا ويعني اقتصاديا
على البلد ام هناك ناس تشتغل لعناصر خ
لاسباب خرجيه انظر ماذا يحدث الان في
البلد ان كنا سنذهب بذلك ان كن ان لم يكن
الخطاب النداء خطابا صادقا ووطنيا مثل ما
يدعون فحبل يعني حبل الكذب قصير لن نذهب
بعيدا وسيحدث ما لا يحمد حقبه وهو ما لا
اتمناه يا استاذ صلاح انا اتمنى من كل
قلبي ان يوفقوا ويتفقوا ويذهبوا للبلد
التي تهدد الان انت ترى العصابات التي
تشتغل بالبلد ونحن مهددون لان تونس ليس
معناها في نفسها كما يخ النحث تونس معناها
في غيرها في جوارها هي قدره على الفعل
يعني هي مخبر يختبر فيه الجميع ماذا يحدث
ان نجحت تونس تعطي نموذجا للدول العربيه
الاخرى ان فشلت تونس فيعني لا اعرف الى
اين سنذهب طيب بس انا اسالك بنفس الاتجاه
يعني انت تصر انه هذا الحزب هو حزب او
حركه وطنيه منبثقه من المجتمع التونسي
تمثل معظم الشرائح الفاعله على الساحه
التونسيه لكن البعض يقول لك في واقع الامر
الامر مكشوف ليس بحاجه ل لا لتحليلات والى
ما هنالك حتى داخل الحركه ذاتها ناهيك عن
الاحزاب الاخرى لا نقول ان الاحزاب الاخرى
ليست مرتبطه بالخارج حتى الان ليس لدينا
احزاب وطنيه خالصه منبثقه من الارض معظم
الاحزاب حتى حزب نداء تونس داخله هذا يمث
تمثل تدعم امريكا اه على الملا يقولون
مثلا محسن مرزوق هو مدعوم امريكيا والطرف
الثاني مدعوم من جهات اخرى عربيه وغير
عربيه والى ما هنالك يعني باختصار شديد
هذه الاحزاب التي ظهرت لا ع لا علاقه لها
لا من بعيد ولا من قريب بطموحات الشباب
التونسي
بطموحات شباب البوعزيزي هذا الحزب هو
عباره عن يعني لا يخدم الا مشغليه الا
مموليه من العرب الذين نجحو رسبوا غيره
هذا يا استاذ فيصل كلام مردود عليك
وسامحني في الكلمه لانه لانه غير صحيح
لانه غير صحيح فهمني لانه داخل ندا تونس
هناك اصوات عاليه البراهين يا استاذ صلاح
ك عفوا كلامك انشائي كلامك يعني انشائي
اعطينا ادله
اد مش اعطيك اولا انا مش اعطيك الادله
اولا انا ثم نقطه مهمه مايلزمنيش نعديها
نداء تونس وقت اللي خذ البلاد وخذ الارث
من الخراب وقت اللي نداء تونس انت تعرف لا
صحيح نقطه واحده فقط
اعطيني انظر انا نلعب دور الضحيه هذا غير
جيد
للبلد احنا احنا رغم اللي خذنا البلد وانت
تعرف
تعرف الاعتصامات وترف التخريب التي حدث 3
اعتصام في دوله لو كانت فرنسا
لقع نعرف وان نعرف الحجم المساهمات والحجم
الهيبات اللي جات في ابان الثوره اكثر من
20 الف مليار جت مساهمات وهبات الدوله اين
ذهبت الترويكا
هي كل ما شئت في الترويكا انا معك كل ما
شئت صدقني قل ما شئت انا اذهب معك اما
تحكيلي على مساله المال انا اعرف هم ابعد
ما يكون عن الا النهب وع السرقه يعني هه
العمليه
اقرب ال سمحني سمحني الف مليارين
ذ شو يعني 200 ال مليار شو مليار شو يعني
عن عننا هيبات
ومساعدات بالدولار ثم 12 مليار دولار لا
لا 12 مليار دولار هذا يا رجل ميزانيه لا
ع م
دولم ما يقارب 12 مليار
دولار يا استاذ انا اعطيك ادله الفرق بيني
وبينك اعطيك ادله اعطيك دليل واحد اعطيك
دليل واحد رغم اني لا اتفق معهم وانتقده
على كل المنابر الاستاذ وزير الخارجيه
السابق في حكومه النهضه في حكومه العرضيه
السييد عبد السلام يعني هو مليون ذهب
قالوا اعطته له الصين والى اخره عمل عليه
فيلم كامل يعني ان الرجل اخذ مصاري وهذا
غير صحيح ثبت من بعد انه غير صحيح يعني
غيره الدكتور المرزوقي رئيس يعني هذا غير
صحيح اعطيني اشياء يا رجل تنفع الناس وتمت
في الارض يا رع فيك ارقام صحيحه انت تحب
تصدقها تصدقها ما تصدقها هذاك راي خاص انا
هذ موجودين هذ قراءه مش خاطه ارقام صحيحه
فهم وان تعرف
حبنك المركزي هنا موج الارقام
موجوده النفط اين تذهب اليوم او موال
البترول بع تونس اين تذهب انا مش نسك انت
جاك جبتها ك الحمله انتم كنتوا في
الحكومه كنت قريب
الاق
انا استشار الذي لا يستشار يا رجل انا
بقيت شهر ونصف بعد استق حبيت اقوللك على
الاقل انت كنت في الدائره الضيقه ا والله
لم اكن صدقني لم اكن قريب ولم ا كنت انت
موجود كيم انت كنت موجود يعني حتى حارس
القصر كان موجود وطباخ يعني موج كان كانت
معناتها عندك مهمه فصل قصر كمستشار انا
لماذا استقلت يا رجل لان لا ما في شي لا
مش كان انت استقلت لانه العديد استقال
بالوضوع
الظرو
وقت الحكم وترب في الانتخابات مش تلقى
البلاد معها اغرقها بالانتدابات العشوائيه
يا ودي عملت لهم مظاهرات رز بالفاكهه
واغتيالات بالعيد واغتيالات البراهمي
المناضلين وحدثت ركعت الاقتصاد اين الذين
ركعوا الاقتصاد اين الذي كان يحكي على قفه
خالت مباركه اين هو اليوم الناس تموت جوعا
في يا استاذ صلاح انا اقول لك عن شيء
وذكرته للدكتور فيصل يعني هته الثورات
كلها بدون استثناء قدمها شباب في قمه
السلميه للرصاص والموت ولم يكونوا مسلحين
فتحت عليهم ابواب جهنم تمسك يمسك بها شيوخ
يعني في نهايه المطاف يتصارعون اكبر ازمات
الامه العربيه هي نخبها الايديولوجيه عن
بكره ابيها ولا استثني احدا لانني لا
انتمي الى اي تيار يعني اردنا وطالبنا
بسقف وطني في كل المنطقه العربيه على
الاقل في تونس يا اخي تحدث كل مره مصيبه
الكل يريد ان يستثمرها انا انتقد هذا
الاخر ينتقدني هذا يكفر الاخر انتهينا من
المساله الان هل لدينا مشروع وطني لنخرج
البلد على كف عفريت لا نعرف من يتدخل
وماذا يفعل هذا او ذاك لا نعرف هذا الوزير
لمن يشتغل ايران تقريبا تخترق كل الفضاء
الرمزي التونسي الحسينيات في كل مكان يعني
الجماعه طبيعه الحال يعني الحضور الايراني
في تونس هو اقوى من حضور في مناطق اخرى يا
اخي غدا تريد ان نعلن اليمن الجنوبي
واليمن الشمالي يحثنا مثل ما حدث انا
احدثك في مرحله مصليه يا اخي مرحله مفصليه
شهداء يموتون كل يوم انا اطالب بالامن
الجمهوري على عيني وراسي يا اخي انا اطالب
بالسياسيين خذوها الثروات على الاقل هذا
الفقراء هؤلاء لنقف النزيف يا رجل يعني
عندك الايرانيين موجودين في كل مكان
وحسينيات وتشيح قلنا لهم على الاقل الائمه
اتركوا المعتدلين من رايتم فيه خطابا
تكفيريا يا اخي هات الادله وحاكمه اما
اختلف معك اقتلك واضعك في السجن يا اخي
هاتوا برهانكم ان كان مدان طبق عليه
القانون لم طالب بشيء طبق القانون على
السارق وعلى الارهابي وعلى المرتشي وعلى
الجاسوس وعلى الخائن القضاه لديهم مهمه
هامه جدا في هته المرحله يا اخي البلد
امانه في ايديكم الامنيين وحيي كل شرفاء
منهم لكن لا يمكن ان تباع البلد ويذبح
ابناء تونس بهذه انا الامن الرئاسي والله
لا اعرف الليله كيف سو انا انا اكلت معهم
يعني الشباب يعني معيب يا رجل ماشي ماشي
كيف ترد على ذلك والجانب الاقتصادي في
واقع الامر اي ما هي انا اسال هلك ص تقول
لي انه جاءت المليارات ايام الترويكا والى
ما هنالك من هذا الكلام على مستوى حركه
نداء تونس التي تقود البلد الان ما هي
انجازاتكم الاقتصاديه المديونيه ارتفعت من
وقت ترويكا حتى الان من 47 الى 59
التونسيون بعض التونسيين يتضورون جوعا
ياكلون الاعشاب يطبخون الاعشاب البترول
انت تعرف وضع البترول
وكذا ماذا قدمته احنا يز كما نعاود ناكد
لك اللي حجم الاقتصاد التونسي هو ما يقارب
94 مليار دينار ونعرف اللي التجاره
الموازيه والسوق السوداء اللي مرتبطه
بالتهريب
وارهاب
فقرا
فقرا ث
تهر ثم تهريب
وثي ثم 25% هذ كبار مرتبطين بندا تونس
اقول لا احد فوق القانون حسب واحد تمسكه
الم تمسكوا جماعه بعد اطلق سراحهم بما
فيهم ناس مسؤولين كبار في الامن وفي الجيش
يا رجل يعني تمسكوا في رجل عنده شاحنه
يوكل في خمسه صغار وامهم القانون ماث
بالنسبه للقانون لازم يطبق
النس القانون هذا
ينطبق اعطيك قضيه اخ لحظه لحظه يا استاذ
صلاح عبد الفتاح سعيد الرجل قدم فقط روايه
مخالفه للروايه الرسميه في اعتداءات سوس
وذكر السيد احمد صواب رئيس المرصد الوطني
للقضاء قال انهم سلخوا سلخا الرجل قدم
روايه الى الان في السجن يا رجل وتقوللي
حريات امه تموت كل يوم لانه ما عند بواكي
له يعني قمع حريات يعني القبق على الضعيف
بس بس بس دكتور خلينا سناتي الى موضوع
الحريات بس بالموضوع الاقتصادي قطعتك
ووقفت لم تكمل هو هو قص عل فهمني قلتله
بالنسبه لتطبيق القانون ما ثماش هذايا
تاجر صغير وتاجر كبير فهمني ثم كل ما هو
مخالف بالقانون يلزم يطبق عليه القانون
ماماش فهمني مهما كانت الاشخاص هذ يلزم
نحاول باش نلوج الحلول للناس هده تستطيعون
ب س نستطيع ذ نستطيع ذلك وقت اللي يبدا ثم
استقرار امني وقت اللي نبدا كنا نفكر
بتفكير وطني وقت اللي نبدا كنا مجموعه
وطنيه متحده وقت اللي نبدا مش نبدا نخون
في بعضنا مش هذ مشكلت هذ مشكله يا سيدي
هذه مشكله نداء
تونس لماذا هدد 32 عضو بترك بالاستقاله
انا نعاود نرجعلك بالنسبه ل 32 النائب
اللي هدوا بالاستقاله مشكله هي اختلاف في
الرؤىه بالنسبه للمؤتمر بالنسبه لانتخابات
المؤتمر حزب فاشل ح غير متس لا لا لا لا
مش صحيح علاش تحسبه فاشل نختلف في الاراء
نصبح فاشلين هذه هي الديمقراطيه الحقيقيه
وهذ نموذج زم الديمقرا بالهراوات
هذوك حالات شاذه هذوك حالات شاذه طيب بس
دكتور دكتور خلينا ناخذ الجزئيه البسيطه
هذه سنعود الى الاقتص مشان ما تروح حت مش
اه تتحدث انه ليس هناك مشاكل دقيقه هناك
مشكله كبرى تتمثل في ان هذا الرئيس يريد
ان يقلد زملائه في سوريا ومصر وليبيا الا
وهو توريث السلطه توريث السلطه طيب هل
حاول الرئيس التونسي الرئيس التونسي
الحالي دقيقه ان يورث السلطه او رئاسه
الحزب لابنه حافظ بس دقيقه يا اخي قايد
السبسي عندما جاء رفع شعار نحن البرق
البورقيبي الجدد اذا صح التعبير ولا لا
لكنه ل على الاقل لكنه ضرب عرض الحائط بكل
تقاليد بورقيبه بورقيبه على الاقل لديه
مقوله مشهوره تقول السلطه لا تلد فلماذا
هذا الرجل يريد ان يورث السلطه الم يرى
ماذا انتج التوريث في سوريا وفي ليبيا وفي
مصر وفي كل هذه البلدان لماذا يريد ان
يعيد الكر استاذ هذا كلام ماهوش صحيح ماه
صحيح ماهوش كل التونسيين انا واحد تونسي
على الاقل ما تقولش كل التونسيين على
الاقل انا هذا مش صحيح اولا انت تعرف ثم
الدستور
وتعرف لا انا بن علي لا لاا ما وصلناش عن
بن علي احنا بن علي مرحله وميت على روحها
ماش عملنا ث انت تعرف المجتمع المدني انت
تعرف المجتمع المدني وتعرف المنظمات
المهنيه ودورها وتعرف سمحني سمحني تعرف
حتى من المجتمع المدني حتى ناس بالنسبه
لحضور لاعضاء مجلس النواب ويعرفوا يطلعوا
ك بقداش هذايا قداش حضر من الحصه وقداش ما
حضرش من الحصه دونك اليوم المجتمع المجتمع
المدني هو كما الحكم وبالتالي ما يمج حتى
حد مهما كانت القيمه تعه مهما كانت
المسؤوليه يتحملها باش يمج يدوس الدستور
وعمليه التوريث هذه مغالطه للراي العام مش
موجوده عمليه التوريث واكثر من هك انت
تعرف ثم في في اجتماع وفي وعلى الاعلام
وفي الصحافه وقالها حافظ قائد السبسي اللي
انا مانيش مترشح حتى مس
اولا احنا ا اذا اذا اذا وصل حافظ قائد
السبسي ونزح في انتخابات
وصوته سمحني احنا حزب ديمقراطي حداثي
ودورنا احنا في انتماء الحزب هذايا باش
نكونوا ندافع الحريه داخل الحزب هذا
سمحي تشوش افكارنا مناش معناتها ناس
داخلين الحزب باش نصفق هذا يستحيل وانت
تشوف الحراك الموجود داخل نداء تونس هي
نقطه ايجابيه ومكن كان شفت انت العالم
كامل معناتها لا بندا تونس وعكس الاحزاب
الاخرى رغم المشاكل هذيه حزب نداء تونس
مافيش انقسامات في اختلافات في الاراء
ونرا الاختلافات والاختلافات في الاراء
سمحني سمحني
س هذ الا لا ماهيش تشققات اختلافات في
الاراء فهمني ماهوش تصدع اعطيني شكون
انسحب من تونس
ق الر جا من اميكا بينقلب
قال على حد انا كل واحد يتحمل مسؤوليه
الكلام اللي يقوله وثانيا لمحسن مرزوق
حافظ قاد السبسي معناتها تسحبوا انت هذوما
الحزب فييه كان محسر مرزوق وحفظ سمحني
نكمل لان هذ فيها مس من القيادات الموجوده
داخل ندا تونس سح خ نكمل فكركم فكر لان
هناك مس من القيادات داخل ندا تونس
والاجتماعات اللي وقعت باش نعطيك معلومه
هذ صار في اجتماع سوس الاولاني بالكل اللي
حضرت فيه هياكل معناتها ولايه المهديه
وسوسه والمستير وال قروان وحضر سي حافظ
قائد السبسي وحضر سي محسن مرزوق وتكلمنا
بكل حريه وصارت ورشات وخرجنا باتفاقيات
بين
جميع المنضوين والهياكل الحزبيه يا استاذ
سحيف ترد الكلام مهم
جدا كلام يعني حسنا انا اتمنى ان يكون
كلامك صحيح لكن اغلب كلامك انشاء لا مش
انشاء انا نع هذا مش صحيح انا
نع لا سمحني سمحني سمحني انا انا هو يقولي
كلامك انشاء هذا مش صحيح انا نعطيك في
حقائق انا عايش فيهم انا عايش فيه الحزب
مش انت انت يمكن تبع الفيسبوك تشوف
بالصحافه انا ب نحكي من داخل الحزب حاجه
اخرى زمك تعرفها يا استاذ وانت سي فيصل
انا يعرفوني
معنتها معارض شرس داخل نداء تونس ما معنى
معارض شرس مهما كانت التجاوزات بخاف حتى
من حد جميل جميل وان عندي كتابات سامحني
انت وقت اللي وقعت هذه معلومه وموجوده في
الصحافه في 3 اوت 2015 وم في واضح وقت
اللي صارت معناتها التعيينات اللي حسينا
فيها بعض الولاءات فهمني حسينا فيها بعض
الولاءات وقفنا وقلنا لا للتعيينات هذيه
وت داخل
الحجا يعني نحن ايضا لماذا نصور لماذا
نحاول ان نصور هذا النداء على يعني وكانه
يعمل في في مجال لا يراقب احد لا يتكلم
عنه احد يقول لك الرجل اكبر المعارضين
واقوى المعارضين هم من داخل الحركه ذاته
فما بالك ان هناك مجتمعا مدنيا قويا في
تونس على عكس كل الدول العربيه اذا
العمليه ليست سائبه اذا صح التعبير كيف
ترد وعاوز تفند هذا الكلام على موضوع على
موضوع الصراعات داخل الكذا والتوريث والى
ما هنالك اولا مساله مساله المجتمع المدني
انا اكاد اجزم انه قانونيا في منطق الاجت
الجماع البشري ان دوله في ظرف خمس سنوات
تتحول من صحراء قاحله استبداد الى جنه
المجتمع المدني هذا لا يستوي تحليليا على
الاقل هذه نقطه اولى يعني هناك محاولات
صحيح لكن هناك اولا عديد المنظمات التي
تشتغل بالمال لاطراف داخليه وخارجيه حتى
الصحف وراءها دائما رجال الاعمال
وحتى دكاكين لتصفيه حسابات هذه النقطه
الاولى النقطه الثانيه هو ان الاستاذ صلاح
يقول انه لا يوجد توريث الى غير ذلك اتمنى
ذلك واصدق لكن انا لا اعطي الثقه لمن يعني
لا يؤكل الانسان مرتين من نفس الكتف يا
اخي هؤلاء سيورث العمليه لان هناك نوع من
محاوله التوريث اعطيك الادله لو كان ذلك
كذلك الاستاذ كما ذكرت لك ابر رئيس
الجمهوريه انا ليس لدي ضده هو او رئيس
اطلاقا اي شيء لكن المبدا نفسه ان تقوم
ثوره شباب يراسها شيخ ثم يمرر العمليه
لابنه او يهددنا بالخراب فهذه كارثه كبرى
المساله الثانيه ان تعرف انت ولا فائده ان
ندخل في تفاصيل المسائل الماديه التي حدثت
وكيف ان الجماعه عاجزون يعني انت تعرف
واسال اي تونسي ان الوضع على حافه
الانهيار يعني ان كانهم كذلك ويقولون لنا
عندنا فرق يمكن ان ان تنشئ اربع حكومات هي
حكومه واحده وسيحدث فها تحوير وزاري
مباشره يعني الجماعه الذين يحكمون اليوم
تونس بما فيهم نواب داخل قبه البرلمان هم
بن علي بينكهه ثوريه يحاولون اعاده انتاج
الاستبداد بنكهه جديده ثوريه يعرفون ان
الجدار الخوف السابق الذي كان ابن علي
مقيمه سقط وانهار ولن يعود الى الوراء اذا
ماذا يفعلون يتركون بعض هامش الحريه كما
فعل ابن علي في خطاب 7 نوفمبر عندما قال
بلغ الشعب التونسي من الوعي ما بلغه ولا
رئاسه مدى الحياه وسنعطي الاحزاب وحر ذلك
ثم بعد ذلك انقظ على الجميع نحن لا نثق في
احد على مستوى السلطه لانه لا يوجد زعيم
عربي تقريبا في الجمهوريات العربيه قدم
السلطه الا بعد تخريب البلد وخراب انظر
جيدا انا لا اثق في النوايا وليست لدي
ضمانات الدستور هذا ابن علي كان دائما
ينهي خطاباته بقول اعملوا فسير الله عمله
ورسوله والمؤمنون بعد وجدنا الايه على
خزينه النهب تتذكرها تع الاموال يعني كفى
ضحكا على الذقون انظر سيدي انا والله يا
استاذ صلاح انت وكل الدائي على راسي لا
عندي معكم مشكل لكن كيف نعيد انتاج
الاستبداد كيف نعيد عمليه انتاج الاستبداد
بهذا الغباء يا رجل يعني انظر هناك تماسيح
كبار في نداء تونس وتعريفهم بالاسم ولا
فائده في ذكر الاسماء هم يملكون الاموال
داخل تونس وخارجها وهم من يحركون خيوط
اللعبه لانهم هم انفسهم وكلاء اناس اخرين
يعني القرار داخل نداء تونس ليس بيد نداء
تونس حتى ولو كانت عندهم النيه الصادقه في
ذلك يعني المشكل داخل النخب العربيه هي
انها نخب تشتغل بالوكاله لغيرها وهذه هي
الكارثه العظمى انا اتمنى ان اصدقهم اتمنى
ان اكون مخطئ واتمنى يعني ان اكون عميل
العملاء ومخر بس كي لا كي لا نبتعد كثيرا
عن موضوع الاستبداد انتم تتهمون هذه
الحركه الان تحديدا بانها تريد اعاده
بناء جدار الخوف اذا صح التعبير واعاده
دوله البوليس والاستبداد والى ما هنالك من
هذا الكلام اليس هناك الكثير من المبالغه
في هذا الكلام ما هي الامثله الت انا
اعطيك ادله يعني هناك على الاقل عوده
للتعذيب في تونس وهذا هذه وسمه عار للشباب
الذي مات من اجل ذلك انا اعطيتك مثال عبد
الفتاح سعيد اعطيك مثال يعني وليد دنجيز
اعطيك مثال ق رحومه انظروا حريه وانصاف
يعني المنظمه تعطيك يعني توثيق للعمليات
والانتهاكات التي تحدث وهي وصمه عار لجهاز
الامن وشرفاء الامنيين من ح
وخذها مثال في تونس حريه وان من ورا جمعيه
حريه وانف انت جاوبني سش تونس وليدز تح
وليدز
تحذ لافعل
معي استفعل معك تركتك
ترت اكثر من وقت انا ثم نقطه مهمه برش
اولا الحقيقه والك السيده سهام بن سدرين
السيده سهام بن سدرين ف ندع حريه وانص الم
يقع الانقلاب عليها وتهديدها من داخل
عندما تسلمت السلطه ولم تتركوها تح الث
ماه صحيح هي هي انت شوف توا بالنسبه لهيئه
الحقيقه والكرامه هي الهيئه سته قدموا
استقالتها من هنا هذا ن لا موجود ماهو
صحيح اخترا احنا ما كناش في الحكم سامحني
احنا لم نكن في الحكم وقت اللي صار وقت
اللي صار سمحني عندما وقع وقع انتخاب هذه
هيئه الحقيقه والكرامه نداء تونس ما كانش
في الحكم
كان هو كيفاش احنا ندا تونس اخلقنا وعملنا
فيها وعملنا
فيها سامحني اولا
ثم من العيب ان ننكر مع معناتها دور لعبه
سي الباجي قائد السبسي وقت اللي تحمل
رئاسه الحكومه في الظرف اليب هذاك ومن
العيب ان نكر كيفاش معناتها معناتها وصل
واعطا الحكم للترك بعد الانخابات في
اكتوبر معناتها 201 معناتها بطريقه حضاريه
هذا صحيح حتى هم سلمكم السلطه بطريقه
حضاريه هل انقلبوا عنكم المرزوقي خارج من
قرطاج ل سيبونا سلطه ه هم انتخبوا لمده
سنه قعدوا ثلاث س
سنين بتعد كثيرا كيف ترد على هذه نقطه
مهمه جدا كل الشباب التونسي بدا يتكلم
عنها بحراره انه انتم تعيدون دوله
الاستبداد دوله البوليس دوله كذا ليس فقط
التعذيب ال معالجه الملف الاسلاميين عدتم
الى الاجتثاث والاقصاء والاستئصال بحق
الاسلاميين مراقبه المساجد اقصاء الائمه
ملاحقه كل من يقول الله اكبر كيف تختلفون
عن بن علي هذا غير ص كيف غير
صحححح سحني
هذا لا موجود ثم ماك تعرف انت مش شد امام
جامع نعرفهم صتو في حكم الترويكا كانوا
دعاه للارهاب وبرشا في التصفير لسوريا شنو
غير صحيح كل شي لا لا كلام صحيح كلام موثق
كلام موثق وكلام صحيح انا
ماماش امام جمع اللخمي امام جمع اللخمي ما
هي تهمته بالله ما هي تهمتها قي الاستاذ
اللخمي ما ما يتهم هذا
مربحي كان عنده معناتها يدعو معناتها في
برشا خطابات معناتها الى الى
التفرقه ولعب دور انتخابي للمرزوقي هذا
يكون بالعكس ماو ماهو انسان ماه يعني
اهالي صفاقص اهالي صفاق يصلون وراه بمئات
الالاف كل مئات
الايح
منب النو يعيش
القصص عف عف انتم لكل تونس لكل تونس بس
عندما يسال مثلا واحد يقوللك رئيس
الجمهوريه منذ تسلم الحكم لم يقل لم يقم
بزياره اي مدينه داخليه خلاف سوس
والمنستير الاولى بسبب حادث ارهابي
والثانيه في ذكرى وفاه بورقيبه ونسيانها
انه رئيس كل التونسيين رئيس الجمهوريه
الغائب جسما عن الواقع التونسي واذا حضر
فهو حاضر في ازمه حزبه المتشقق وفي جميع
الاحوال لم ينتقل وهو رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي والقائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه مره
واحده لمعاينه الوضع في المنطقه العسكريه
في المنطقه الحدوديه الجبليه الغربيه او
المنطقه الجنوبيه او ل مؤازره عائلات
الضحايا والى ما هنالك وتيجي بتقول لي هذا
حزب س
هذا
صحيح صحيح هذ هذا كلام مردود
للناس تخرج وتسوق في الكلام هذا ت انت
تعرف رئيس الجمهوريه اولا مناش حكم رئاسي
مناش حكم رئاسي وتعرف انت شنو دور رئيس
الجمهوريه خاصه الخارجيه سياسه الخارجيه
فهمني
وهو سمحني لا سمحني لا بالعكس العلاقات مع
بشار
الاس شو شوف اذا انت عندك مشاكل مع بش
الاسد احنا
احنا
سحيح سمحني احنا عننا توانسه اولا عننا
توانسه في سوريا ومن مصلحتنا باش نحافظوا
على توانس اللي موجودين في سوريا يسيط على
سوريا يسيطر على بعض امتار في المهم لا مش
صحيح احنا نحكي عننا مهما كان يبش حتى
عننا تونسي داش حتى عننا واحد تونسي احنا
يلزمنا نخم في التانس الموجودين داخل تونس
تون قرح ال
ق داهمنا مشان ما ناخذها كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام نفى ملف التعذيب نفى ملف عوده دوله
البوليس والاستبداد نفى انه الدوله او هذا
الحزب يلاحق الاسلاميين والبعض يقول في
واقع الامر ان الهدف الاساسي من مجيء هذا
الحزب الى السلطه هو استئصال الاسلاميين
والوقوف في وجه الاسلام واعاده الكره الى
ايام بن علي كيف ترد نعم يعني هو يعرف
وجميع التونسيين يعرفون ان هو يعيد ان
يحيي الاستبداد وينفخ في جثه ميته ولا
يمكن احياء الاستبداد اطلاقا لان جدار
الخوف سقط نحن قلنا دائما ان الصراع الذي
يحدث في نداء تونس هو صراع على السلطه
وعلى النفوذ لان كل المنوت الانقلابيه في
مرحله معنه تصفي بعضها مثل ما فعل بورقيبه
عام 34 1934 عندما انقلب على الثعالبي وبن
علي عندما انقلب عليه يعني كل واحد ينقلب
عن الاخر ليستمد السلوك الذي نراه في عزل
الائمه الوسطيين السلوك الذي نراه في
اغلاق الجمعيات عوده التعذيب في التهميش
الاجتماعي في الاحتقار في بيع البلد في كل
المظاهر الا الاجتماعيه التي نراه ليس الا
مؤشرا على عوده الاستبداد واتمنى ان اكون
خاطئا عندما ذكرت لك اسماء اناس ماتوا تحت
التعذيب بالنسبه لي ان يموت مواطن تونسي
تحت التعذيب بعد الثوره فهذه عار على من
ماتوا شهداء من اجل ان يتحرر التونسيون من
القبضه الامنيه نحن نعاقب هل تعتقد استاذ
صلاح انه يعني صدفه جاء الارهاب للقصر
وسيدي بوزيد ليعاقبه لانهم فقراء وهم مهد
الثوره التونسيه يعني كيف يحدث الارهاب
ياتي من يعني من من من الحدود الجزائر
الحركات الارهابيه هناك ثم يعني نضع جدار
عازل مع ليبيا اللي هي امتداد للعمق
التونسي يعني هذا التصرف الذي يحدث اليوم
يعني يمكن ان يؤدي بالبلد الى الخراب يعني
التصرف الذي يحدث سواء اعلامي هل الاعلام
التونسي هذا اعلام يمكن ان نقابل به رب
العالمين هذا اعلام العار هذه مجال السوء
هذا تجييش للناس هذا متاجره بالام الناس
ان تاتي تخاطب التونسيين في يعني خاصه ك
رموز بن علي عادوا الى الوجه عادوا هؤلاء
ليسوا خطرا المشكل الاخطر لان تعلقنا بهم
هناك حرب على القيم وهذه الحرب تؤدي الى
تجفيف القيم وتجفيف القيم يؤدي الى الياس
والياس يدفع الى الارهاب انا معك يعني ما
يحدث في تونس جريمه في حق الثوره وفي حق
الشهداء ليس انشاء يعني انا عندما اقول لك
انه مات وليد دنجيز اعرف انه مات عندما
اقول لك قيس بن رحومه رجع الى امه مخاط
المسكينه عندما اقول لك انه عبد الفتاح
السعيد يعني لانه اعطى رايه عندما اقول لك
انتب سامحني الهناء تتحمل مسؤوليه ندات
تونس انت السلطه انت في السلطه بس باختصار
شديد بس باختصار شديد الوقت دهنا بدي
اعطيك بس
باختصار اين يذهب او اين تذهب حركه نداء
تونس بتونس بجملتين انتهى الوقت يزبك تعرف
اللي حركه نداء تونس هي مؤتمنه على مستقبل
تونس وحركه نداء تونس هي معناتها حزب
معناتها متفتح على جميع الاحزاب واحنا
ماحنا نسمعوا كل المقترحات من الاحزاب
الوطنيه والمنظمات المهنيه والمجتمع
المدني و ناخذهم اهداف الثوره وارجاع
السياده الوطنيه اللي كانت مفقوده سصار
اين تذهب هذه الحركه بتونس باختصار هذه
الحركه تذهب الى حتفها لانها فقد الشيء لا
يعطيه خاصه انها تعيد انتاج شروط
الاستبداد الوضع تغير وهم يعتقدون انهم
يمكن ان يعيدوا هذه العمليه الشعب التونسي
العظيم هو الوصي على ثورته وعلى شعاراتها
الشعار الاول كان التشغيل استحقاق يا
عصابه السراق اما نحن او عصابه السراق
اشكرك جزيل الشكر مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبقى
لنا الى ان اشكر ضيفين الد صالح حاج عمر
والدكتور محمد هنيد نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء
المقبل فحتى ذلك الحين وفيصل قاسم يحييكم
من الدوحه الى اللقاء
ي